the Pentagon is considering a plan to
add up to 7,000 additional US forces to
the Middle East to counter what it sees
as an increasing threat from Iran that
is according to two US defense officials
I will ask the National Security Advisor
about that in just a bit but the
Pentagon's top policy adviser says the
defense secretary has not officially
made any decision tonight the State
Department is putting a very large
number on the total of Iranian civilians
killed in massive demonstrations there
over that hike and gasoline prices we're
learning about US seizure also of
missile parts allegedly being smuggled
to Yemeni rebels correspondent ray yanks
reports on Iran tonight from Lisbon
Portugal overnight the US Navy reported
seizing a cache of Iranian missile parts
set to be delivered to rebels in Yemen
the operation highlighted the Western
efforts to counter Iranian threats
against American allies in the region as
Israel and the u.s. worked towards a
joint defense agreement Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu traveled to
Portugal Wednesday to meet with US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo to
discuss rising tensions with Iran we're
seeing the Iranian Empire totter and I
think it's important to increase this
pressure against the Iranian aggression
despite the Trump administration working
to disengage from the Middle East the
relationship between the Americans and
Israelis remains strong this week
President Trump Secretary Pompeo and
Prime Minister Netanyahu all reaffirmed
their support of anti-government
protesters in Iran Iraq and Lebanon the
State Department suggested today that
more than a thousand people have been
killed by government forces in the
ongoing Iranian protests America will
always stand with the Iranian people in
their righteous struggle for freedom
iran's Foreign Minister Mohammed Zarif
today calling the administration's
comments about US sanctions against Iran
an admission of quote economic terrorism
as the region slides towards a larger
conflict Iranian president Hassan
rouhani is leaving the door open to
negotiations we haven't closed the
windows of negotiations if they are
ready to lift the sanctions we are ready
to talk and negotiate even at the level
of the heads of the five plus one
heads of countries and we have clearly
declared there before a new report today
says that Iran is building a missile
stockpile in Iraq that could threaten
Saudi Arabia Israel and US troops in the
region overnight airstrikes targeted a
separate weapon stockpile in eastern
Syria when asked whether or not Israel
was behind those strikes Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu told Fox
he doesn't comment on those types of
questions right trained yangste in
Portugal tre thanks